[Music]
hey my name is Ellie Hughes I worked
android for a while now and actually my
first job on Android was working on the
Java core libraries and actually
cleaning up some of the bugs in our j'ni
so first off I'll show you what you're
probably expecting to see when you think
j'ni which is code that looks like this
and I I'm guessing no one can tell that
the code that actually does anything
useful isn't on that screen yet and I'm
guessing that no one can tell me within
five seconds where the useful line in
that either is so like this this is this
talk is basically how to not do that how
do we get away from that and the the one
line answer is use C++ better if you if
you if you're using the C API S which is
what most people do it's really tricky
you end up with this sort of go-to fail
style or you have the sort of nested-if
style that we had there and there are a
lot of special cases as well like you
know I'm trying to throw an exception
but there's already an exception pending
what do i do there how do i chain that
to be the cause of the previous xh
exception so don't like that in every
single J&I method right at once and in
particular have classes that let you use
a string as a string like you know user
J string as if it's a dead string
similar for arrays you don't want to be
having to deal with like a J byte array
when you could just use operator square
brackets to just use it like a normal
array local references - and there's a
long list of other things but there's
strings and primitive arrays I think are
the two major ones and most of the
benefit you get from that exceptions
harder than they look and the the sort
of raw primitives you get in J and I are
not super useful the they expect you to
find the class yourself they expect you
to create an instance if you if you want
to actually include a proper detail
message or a cause you end up doing
weird things like you know I need to
find the constructor for my for this
exception and then I need to invoke the
consort blah blah blah it's a lot of
code especially if you deal with the
special cases
so having
a function that just takes a printf
style format string is a huge relief and
right so I've been talking about this
kind of in the abstract I'm saying you
should do these things there are many
choices that you can use for this and I
think a problem a lot of people have is
they get hung up on like what's the
exact perfect way to do this what's the
best
doesn't matter any of these are better
than writing the kind of code that we
saw on the first couple of slides
Android itself uses live native helper
which you can find in AOSP it's in the
root directory as a bunch of header only
stuff for doing the things that I've
been talking about or if you don't like
any of the others on the internet you
can just write your own that they're
really not that hard so what does it
look like if you actually do switch to
using something like this this is the
same code this is the same two slides
that we had before
now condense to one I think five seconds
is plenty of time for you to actually
see which is the line that actually does
the work there you can make this shorter
you don't actually need to have the
style where we we have the constructors
and then we check like did that actually
work if you're prepared to use C++
exceptions and do some kind of
transformation but that's kind of a more
advanced topic I think this gets you 90%
of the benefit for like 20% of the
efforts so this this is this is what
Android does internally this is actually
what the code looks like in Android for
that call so that was a really simple
thing where there really was just one
line of active ingredient in there but
this scales really well and our
recommendation is that you actually you
try to keep your code like that so don't
mix all the J&I boilerplate stuff in
with your actual code keep those
separate in the same way that you
wouldn't you know it's on the other end
of the spectrum if you wouldn't sort of
mix your your business logic and your UI
rendering stuff down here it's it's
similar sort of advice don't do that and
again if you want a good example of this
the Android system OS class is
implemented in exactly this way that the
the implementation super repetitive
really boring and that's the way we like
it it's hard to make mistakes I'm
running out of time so I'll
very quickly if you if you need to worry
about old Android releases and you have
multiple ISO files that can get very
tricky we recommend that you consider
the real Inca project you can find that
on github
the storing ISO files uncompressed that
was mentioned earlier in the keynote one
big library is generally better than
lots of small libraries thank you if you
have questions come and find me I'll be
in I'll be doing open house all
afternoon
so thank you
[Music]